[Music]
foreign
this is our house renovation tour we
bought this house for three million
pounds and we're spending a load more
money on it making it our own we're
renting a house down the road because
she's got so much work going on but we
want to do a video to sort of show you
the the process of the actual build so
it's kind of at the pizza it's excited
there's lots going on let's show you
around let's go
so before you may remember this was a
garage and we completely demolished it
demolish it though we did we did it we
knocked it to the ground it wasn't
locked to the ground babe I got pictures
listen we took the roof off and then we
removed some of the walls no we didn't
we knocked it down I'm gonna find the
video proof we demolished I've got the
receipts we demolished it are you
telling me come on let's come come on
you're telling me that there was still
stuff standing it wasn't completely gone
yeah it was so wrong no no sir what
happened was we took the roof off yeah
it was um and then we've extended to the
top and then some of the walls we had to
cut through to make openings but we
didn't demolish it to the ground but
they did have to add some Foundation to
the ground I remember seeing it with
nothing there someone said
foreign
this was a garage but I personally feel
that garages are overrated do you feel
that yeah because you end up with just
lots of junk in them you don't actually
ever use them and when you've got
private Gates and stuff like that and
your cars you've got full-time security
and like what's the point of having a
garage you know so we decided to knock
it down to the ground and demolish it
and build instead instead build this
come on have a look around
so this area is going to be my recording
studio so this is where we're going to
film with us on a Wednesday this is
where I'm going to film a lot of my
YouTube videos you're going to see a
background we're going to have the uh
Brands Samuel Leeds logo or something TV
there nice beautiful podcast type tables
here where I can interview people on
Windows on a Wednesday and so forth so
this is going to be my little space it's
a really good space yeah it is really I
love those doors as well because so
before this was just like a complete War
so we've opened it up now so you've got
bifold doors that go out straight into
the garden yeah we have to we did have
to get planning permission to do this
because we were demolishing it to the
ground and stuff we needed planning
permission which took about it took
about three months didn't it to get
planned it took a while yeah yeah and
also because there's a listed building
like next door to us even though you
can't see there's the building and they
can't see us they didn't like our
initial design today because Amanda made
it like really glass it was like a glass
yeah and I said nah so we wanted to have
like like complete open doors up here a
bit like that side but they wouldn't let
us do it at the front so we did it at
the back they allowed us to do that so
yeah you can't do everything you want
just because you own the house you can't
just do anything you want you've still
got to comply with the Council planning
regulations so this is the podcast room
now if you come to a Windows on a
Wednesday and you're sitting here with
me when this is all finished and you
need to go to the toilet no problem you
don't have to go to the house
you can go in fact now even if you want
to come take a shower no bro you want to
take a shower you're in the middle of
the family Windows do have a quick
shower break no problem man you come
through
you're gonna be able to take a shower
right here shower toilet little small
bathroom I like this I know it's really
nice it's going to look really good as
well because the the mirrors are going
to be litter and things like that so
it's going to look really really nice by
the way you do realize I'm gonna hunt
down the footage or the pictures of it
being completely demolished and I'm
gonna put it as b-roll next video I'll
wait to see you who do you think is
right who do you think's right Amanda
Amanda she's a quality surveyor cost
manager has mainly been involved or me
who remembers seeing it demolished who
do you think is right comment below at
the end of the video we will find that
and I will put the evidence
so upstairs
whoa
this room is gonna be
my second office
so I'm planning to have an office desk
here
by the way I'm one of those guys I can't
have my back exposed
so I wouldn't be able to possible they
were talking about having my desk
like in the middle of the room
right here nothing look out the window
but I'm thinking what happens if someone
comes up the stairs behind me
it's weird so my my desk is going to be
I'm going to be here
and then what we're gonna do around the
river she's not gonna be like a lounge
yeah it's going to be like a lounge area
so there's going to be some seating and
then just over there there's going to be
like a little Kitchener area so a cooker
tap for hot water a little dish
basically a little fridge this is gonna
be like we're gonna have the um main
house the Amanda house
just so that like if I'm getting guests
and stuff I think we don't have to
disturb your pieces that what it is you
know I mean because if we've not got a
kitchen and I've got people over if I'm
having meetings and stuff because
initially he was like oh no you can just
bring drinks over from and I was
thinking what from the kitchen in there
and then it's a long walk it is a long
walk so I'm quite pleased with this it's
very light I love the windows I love how
Airy it is and it's quite spacious I
would much rather have this than the
garage oh yeah and if ever we sell the
house and someone wants to they could
always build a garage like at the front
end of the house I don't want anyone
you'd need one but I don't think so we
never used it we never we just had our
garage just consult just consisted of a
Christmas tree because the thing is this
as well like
we don't need tools when you don't have
a lot of money
you have to do everything yourself right
cut your own garden wash your car all
that kind of stuff so you need a
lawnmower you need tool boxes you need
all this stuff and where does it go in
the garage we don't need that stuff
because we have people that wash the car
we have people that cut the grass and
and so we don't need a garage what we
need is studio and a Samuel lounge and
it's way better use this I like it
[Music]
where we've changed things up as well
um we wanted an outdoor gym yes I mean
we've got an indoor gym a small kind of
indoor gym but there's nothing nicer I
think than working outside in the summer
so we just put this whole decking area
here which to be honest I love this area
I know it's great I think it's just
brilliant I think it's gonna be really
good in the summer yeah we're going to
have a boxing ring here just just a
small one 12 foot by 12 foot which we
just bought actually so this is just
came a couple days ago so this is the
boxing ring
and we've already had a couple of
sparring sessions me and Amanda and
these are a tough Contender
um and then yeah so ring here then we're
just gonna put I don't know exactly what
we're gonna have I'm thinking some
boxing bags bench press some just some
stuff Outdoors yeah you know we're going
to also put like a canopy outside is
that what it is yes I think it's a pair
of girls to stop the rain yeah so you
can you can shut the louvers and then
the rain won't come in you can have it
open yeah you can have it open up yeah
if it's rainy have it closed so that's
this we've also as well recently got
some palm trees so they're quite
expensive actually palm trees cost a lot
so we've got these palm trees put in
with my my beautiful hammock
again you can just hear so much going on
it's so noisy and all the scaffolding
and there's constantly just people here
that's why we're renting another house
at the moment down the road so kind of
nipping back and forth it's only about
two minutes away isn't it yeah hammock
love this I know that's been just like a
perfect addition
[Music]
I blend in with the hammock yeah you did
like a chameleon right now blending in
you like fall asleep out here don't you
oh yeah
[Music]
yeah you know what it is in here
it's like your body just rests in a way
that it can't when you're in bed when
you're in bed
arms everywhere now
floating complete rest
ah and palm trees either side of me
because palm trees represent freedom
love it here
right let's go
what's next Swim Spa
what tell what the plan is with the swim
spa so our plan with the swim spa is to
have it sunken into the ground we're
going to have it yeah they're going to
dig a big hole put it in the ground have
some decking around it have some sun
loungers basically have it feeling like
we're in Spain but we're in England
because without the sunshine I know that
was Sunshine we get really good Sun
though when it's hot the Sun but the
swim spot you can go in it anytime oh
yeah we can use it anytime it's like a
hot jacuzzi but big can kind of swim in
it yeah so I love that that's been an
asset and a really big so yeah so not
loads to do outside we're kind of get in
there really aren't we also as well I
want to get rid of all I just want the
whole garden to run clean along here who
needs this type of thing
you know what I mean like what's this
you hate shrubs these whole thing this
whole area needs to go so yeah that's
the outside wrap around inside
we've got a lot going on inside I know
yeah we've had a lot you show them a
quick peek inside I know it's messy yeah
I know it's not that tidy Quick Pick
Quick Pick all right here we go we'll go
through the back
[Music]
[Applause]
so the kitchen we just had the kitchen
completely redone I love the kitchen I
absolutely love the kitchen yeah I like
it um so before if you've seen our
previous house tour it was like a cream
yeah with a wood worktop that was about
this thick behind me the wooden worktop
was like a really expensive wooden
worktop but you didn't like it so we
sold it we sold it for quite a bit
didn't we I know we did someone someone
who was building the house bought our
old kitchen because they wanted it in
there we bought the new we sold that for
six grand and we bought this this was
about I don't remember yeah I don't
remember it was in the tens of thousands
yeah but um yeah so this is the kitchen
and also in the kitchen we're still
thinking about
um a feature yeah right I haven't
decided yet yeah kitchen's great and
also as well you got like that's what
that's where we work out we've got the
playroom gym utility back there this has
all been done up as well this area again
this was all wood yeah the wood effect
now we've got the marble effect and the
dials really really nice there's toilet
we've also sorry changed all this so we
had spindles on the stairs yeah we've
changed it all to be how much better
there's so much more light that comes in
and we're also going to be changing our
front door so we're going to have full
length floor ceiling glass either side
and then a big massive front door so
again there's going to be yeah and also
big thing as well we're going to be
doing is the whole front of the house
we've got planning permission except to
put Julia balconies which is just going
to bring in so much light into the house
yeah so lots happening I know
I think that's about it to be honest I
don't think there's much more oh Lounge
that's like the best part I have to
forget oh I love
that was the end of the tour upstairs
we're gonna leave upstairs but I mean
upstairs I'll just say quickly go
upstairs our room upstairs like it's
it's massive
we got a dressing room yeah a nice
ensuite what we're doing because we
don't need as many bedrooms we're
stealing an entire bedroom and then
we're making our own Suite huge you're
having a whole new bedroom for a
dressing room I'm having an addressing
room with my dressing room
use it let's have a quick look let's
have a quick look have a quick look it's
a mess it's a mess but just a quick one
big bedroom one big bedroom two with an
ensuite big bedroom three
big bedroom four with an ensuite this
room
she's asleep right now yeah okay this
room which is our baby's room will be
your dressing room the whole thing
this bathroom which is the kids bathroom
kids don't need two bathrooms this
bathroom we're gonna have
as just an addition to our ensuite why
because Aaron Suite has a small bath let
me show you this
is our ensuite
right but this bath is small for me I'm
a big guy I want a big ensuite knock
down this wall right gone
steal that bathroom have a humongous
ensuite with gold Taps big jacuzzi
it just needs to happen yeah you're sold
on that white gold yeah yeah and then
the bit our room will stay big ah
walking wardrobe which is here I don't
think we can go inside now now we will
go inside but our walking wardrobe which
is here becomes who's walking wardrobe
yours mine but then as well I think this
I think our bedroom will begin right
here
and then we'll just step in here yeah
I'll put a door here yeah vision
and then
and then all this area
okay these are all going to be Juliette
balconies and all down the rooms in our
bedroom we'll have Juliet balconies yeah
so that's the plan are you excited about
that plan yeah
I remember when we talked about our
studio
the studio and it felt like
planning permission
the whole thing it just felt like is it
gonna happen but now it's just happened
better and it's looking really good yeah
from the ground up yeah
you keep trying to get me on that and
I'm like all right Lounge last room most
important right one of the things that
I'm happy to spend money on is comfort
because I think that being when you
spend like for instance our bed our bed
is an expensive bed because when you're
spending eight hours a day in your bed
needs to be comfortable same as the
lounge
so this is the lounge talk about the
lounge what did you why did you go I
can't lie I was scared when you told me
you wanted the this wall black I was
like black yeah you went sore back it
works man she's an interior designer
qualified
I absolutely love the black wall and I
just think it's so simple Now isn't it
but it still looks really nice and like
yesterday I had Tony Ricky Chris my mom
my brother Sienna we were all here and
we were just all just in the lounge yeah
comfortable sat down no problems Ricky
was sat in my corner right there where
was it just big and nice I know big and
nice we had the media wall built out
new TV everything like it's just
brilliant really nice when you're
watching movies and stuff and this sofa
was so expensive like but how fast did
we buy this so if we walked into a sofa
shop and we were just sold instantly
yeah I think this sofa was was it how
much was it like 10 grand 10 000 for a
sofa yeah it is really good so it's so
big if you're spending so much time in
here I say that we don't spend much time
we don't really come here
we've literally got we only sat in here
two or three times since it's been done
but when we do it's nice to see it yeah
it is what they don't teach you a
Harvard Business School see this is the
thing man you want to be successful and
be able to live in nice big houses and
stuff firstly you've got to get educated
super smart right yeah so if you want to
learn about property because we make it
while we were in lockdown okay I was
getting so many land deals on options
getting planning permission profiting
from the planning we bought this house
actually what year was it was it I think
it was I think it was middle of 2021
yeah we put an offer forward it was in
July yeah it was in July we completed
around October November time in 2021
just as we were coming out of lockdown
so while we were in lockdown and
everyone else was struggling and wow my
gosh panicking we were making a killing
in lockdown and we used the money to buy
the house and now we've got you know
obviously a lot of stuff going on with
the house refurbing it but we're going
to add value to it so yeah final
thoughts I'm just excited to see
everything absolutely complete but I'm
really happy I can't believe how much
we've changed the house since we bought
it I can't believe it like a different
house it's a completely different house
yeah awesome as well shout out to the
person that sold this house to us
because when they sold the house to us
we sensed that they were like a bit
unsure about the sales so we were
holding our breath and then the day of
completion they then came to get a
couple things I know and when they came
to the house they looked gutted and I
think I think they'd forgotten how
amazing the house was because the house
wasn't on for sale they just said they
were living abroad and they'd said we're
gonna move back in and we were like we
love the house yeah we offered to buy it
and that's how it came about so yeah I
think there was probably a little bit of
regret for them maybe there was but hey
I wish them all the best and I'm so glad
they sold to us because we love this
house I also we we're in the process of
buying another house as a second home
which I also love just as much I just
love properties I love making money from
properties but also love I just love
develop it's nice developing your own
house yeah so you want to learn about
property come and join me at the
property investors crash course one
pound I'll leave a link in the
description come and meet us learn about
property learn the skills and do the
same thing see you next time
[Music]
thank you